Jane Fonda says we need to imprison
white men Jane Fonda just said quote
it's good for us all to realize there
would be no climate crisis if there was
no racism there would be no climate
crisis if there was no patriarchy a
mindset that sees everything in a
hierarchical way white men are the
things that matter and then everything
else is at the bottom that's the problem
I love She's attacking this hierarchical
white male way of thinking and how does
she do it she arranges it in a hierarchy
of evil people at the very top of the
hierarchy of evilness at the very bottom
of the hierarchy of goodness she puts
the white men okay she says it's a
tragedy that we have to absolutely stop
we have to arrest and jail those men
they're all men okay all those white men
we've got to throw them in jail because
they're pushing global warming maybe
worth pointing out to Hanoi Jane that as
far as Nations go the biggest
contributor to global warming such as it
is is a China